[Music]
Sara's with us in Savannah Georgia
hi Sara how are you good how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
I'm calling because I have a year and a
half left in school I've set out for the
last year did some financial reasons of
course I have 29 thousand in student
loan debt and I'm just trying to figure
out is it worth going back to school so
they got more in debt to completely
degree or just work on tackling the debt
and also I'm currently engaged and we're
trying to do like a cruise wedding so
I'm just trying to figure out which is
that Wow and so what do you make I make
twenty-eight thousand six hundred a
month I mean it here I'm sorry yeah it'd
be nice yeah
and what does he make 26,000 yearly okay
and what are you planning on spending on
your wedding
um well if we knew the cruise
destination is looking at about 5,000
okay and do you have five thousand right
now no when when is the wedding we were
looking at tours November of this year
so can you show you five thousand
between the two of you by then yes we
started budgeting this year and we
figured by the time April comes we
should have at least a five thousand
okay good that's a good plan all right
so we're gonna pay cash for the wedding
your whole wedding expense is five grand
yes
okay it's an inexpensive way to do it
that's good
and kind of a cool thing I like it when
you are married your household income
will be about $55,000 a year okay you
make you have $29,000 in death
do you have any other debt I just bought
a card you just bought a car
yeah because I didn't have my thousand
dollars base for my emergency fund and
my 2010 Ford Fusion needed some repair
like CV axles great minor things but
they still add up mm-hmm so I my
expensive a car did you buy twenty
thousand with the 2014 season you're
kidding me
you spent twenty thousand dollars on a
car yeah and you're broke yes
sell the car okay that was stupid okay
tell me you know that was stupid
I felt the brunt of it acted like three
days later when the general said well
you have 30 days to bring it back and
I'm like I just feel like a scam are you
within the 30 days I brought the vehicle
no I think my 30 days I might have just
ended less week yeah call them and call
them and beg them uh-huh to let to let
the 30 days count and let you take you
back and you go and you go get you a
thousand dollar car okay you know honey
you only don't even don't even start
talking okay not after doing that I'm
giving you hard time you have to know
that was dumb you make $28,000 a year
you signed up for a $20,000 car debt and
you are already $29,000 in that on your
student loans and broke yeah you have to
hear that okay I'm not trying to be mean
to you
but you got to break this thing out of
your brain or you're gonna constantly as
a couple be wandering back into this
mess and I'm not gonna be able to help
you because you're gonna continually go
back to this back to the slaughter I
mean you just walked out right in front
of a gun and said shoot me I mean it
just I don't want I don't want you to
live your life like that honey
so here's what I'm going to do I want
the two of you as my wedding gift to go
through Financial Peace University
that's our nine week series once you get
that car taken back call them today and
once you get your little little beater
car or some kind to get by until you get
some miss mess cleaned up now what were
you studying in school okay a ministry
health care administration okay
and what do you do for a living now I'm
an assistant manager at the DMV okay so
you're not in the healthcare field yeah
do you want to be in the healthcare
field I do okay
can you study that at night and finish
it in pay cash as you go maybe after the
wedding yes but some of the classes do
require me to be in the actual do they
have do they offer them at night yes but
with my work schedule I don't generally
get off in time to pay so close yeah you
might have to rearrange your work
schedule in order to finish your degree
but I don't know that you necessarily
have to do completely all school or all
work my point is maybe we can finish up
school while we're working while we're
married and while we're paying off the
debt and but pay cash for the school as
you go you pay cash for it and whatever
you're going to do don't add debt pay
cash for whatever you do is you go work
your way down through it that way and
and pay cash for cars as we go pay cash
for the wedding you already got that one
on the run good for you that was a good
decision and we'll pay cash for the
cruise wedding and but let's let's say
let's take as many classes as we can and
then if we have to talk to the B&B and
say guys I got a dial back a little bit
cuz I'm this close to finishing and for
one semester here I need to be able to
take off on Thursday nights you know
okay they'll work with you or if they
won't find a different job yeah but I
wouldn't just quit my job to go back to
school full-time no no no okay this more
so for more income okay yeah I think I
think you can make more with your degree
and I think it's a good degree to finish
and and healthcare is a good field to be
in
particularly Healthcare Administration
with as much upheaval and chaos as there
is in that world someone that goes in
there with a cool head in the middle of
all this mess can probably you know do
some good for some companies and theirs
and with a little bit of academic it you
know under your belt so you're right on
track but the glaring thing in this
discussion is
this poor car and please talk them into
you and your fiance go over there and go
hey we just got engaged and you guys
please if even if we have to write you a
check take the count this in the thirty
days even if we give you a thousand
dollars just to say thank you give him a
tip you know to pay the salesmen or
something right but be able to take the
thing back cuz it's just insanity the
numbers on that just take my breath away
how bad they are and I want you to get
because with no card debt and the
wedding is saved up and paid for and
we're paying cash for college as we go
along
and then we can begin to knock out the
twenty nine thousand as well see you're
gonna be in a really good place in a
very short period of time but when you
drop a twenty thousand dollar stupid car
loan in the middle of it it just blows
the thing up it makes it very hard to
pull off so really really really bad
decision there on that one but you can
recover from it let's get out of it
let's do something to get out of that
deal please work very hard to get out of
it and don't use them saying no and
smiling as a as an excuse you've got to
work your way away from that it's just
really really bad so and hold on Kelly
I'll pick up I'm gonna put you through
Financial Peace University is my wedding
present to the two of you what the two
of you to go through the class together
and you'll see what I'm talking about
it'll start to come together for you and
you just you see how avoiding debt
causes you to be in a position to be
outrageously generous and to build well
brenda's with us in phoenix arizona hi
Brenda how are you taking my call sure
what's up in your world well we're in a
big mess I just started listening to you
later about a couple months I read your
book some money makeover and my um my
question is I have a lot of people tell
me I should just do bankruptcy and I
don't wanna go that route and I'd be
like me listening to you so I wanted to
if where am I at
I have babysit one I got my thousand
dollars I'm safe okay how much debt do
you have I have um I have a home equity
from six years ago
a hundred thousand
six years ago sister is it you still
have the home no we lost the home but
the home equity we bought if we got the
hundred to buy the second home which we
lost four homes six years ago okay so
you're a hundred thousand on that and
have you been paying on that
no how long has it been in default it's
six years you've not paid on it in six
years
no okay what else I have a $40,000
medical from two years ago and haven't
paid on it in two years
nope nothing and my dad eighteen
thousand dollars in credit cards and
that there are any collections now so
for the last six years we have not done
anything okay have you been paying on
the credit cards when was the last time
you paid on them I haven't paid on
parties for the last five years okay and
I do have two credit cards for assuming
you know you know there's any papers
food equipment they're sending the women
they actually sent you lawsuit papers or
a letter saying they were going to sue
you there's a law firm that doesn't
matter was it an actual lawsuit long
court documents that said you had a
court date yes it was from last year
okay and and how much are those two
cards those are five thousand and that's
part of the 18 or is that in addition to
the 18 and what is your household income
Oh myself employing with the average of
every year about 60,000 so why have you
not paid bills I don't know I don't know
we just I don't know just I don't know
we kind of just hide under and didn't
take care of it
you know where we are you know we're
being renting for the last since we lost
our home no we I would like to move on
and you know filing a bankruptcy would
clear this hundred and fifty eight
thousand dollars in debt okay that it
looks like you've got it would clear
that at chapter seven would clear that
I'm not sure you're going to qualify for
a chapter seven it might the means test
might throw you into a chapter thirteen
which would cause you to pay payments
into bankruptcy for five years
are you II what was is his income steady
at sixty-five or is he starting to
increase his income it goes up and down
are you working outside the home now I'm
at the position like Awards my kids are
now are going to school and I'm able to
get a job you know in the morning you
know she's the job is weird so different
hours different schedules so I'm doing
one can run the kid around so I'm
considering the job you need to add some
income if you can add twenty thirty
thousand dollars income to this
situation it changes everything yeah
okay so here's the thing if we add up
all that debt and say it's one hundred
and fifty eight thousand hundred sixty
thousand dollars for the debt it is very
very old debt by and large they have
given up on it even the one that serves
you even the one that sued you isn't
doing anything with the lawsuit they
just took a judgment against you but
they're not doing anything with it
meaning they've not come and garnished
wages they've not come and try to take
money out of your bank account or
anything like that so you know they're
not they're not being that aggressive or
proactive I mean they're probably
calling you occasionally some of them
are in raising Cain but they're not
actually doing anything you follow me
and the debt has probably been sold and
if it's been sold a lot of it's been
sold to debt buyers and they buy that at
around a nickel on the dollar
mmm-hmm five cents on the dollar okay
fifty dollars for $1,000 you follow me
which means that if you made them an
offer of ten or fifteen cents on the
dollar you could clear all this debt and
I would take a lot of work to contact
each one of them negotiate with them get
them to accept that but eventually you
could work your way through this for
around ten or fifteen cents on the
dollar no the home equity do send me
enough for last year for twenty five
thousand to say that's a quarter on the
dollar they're already closed but you
don't have twenty five thousand so you'd
have to save up the money to make them
an offer they're going to be the hardest
one starting so you'd have to save up
you need a lump sum in your bank account
and then you call them and go
I have $15,000 cash I will give you
today if you will settle this and
they'll take it they'll take it but
they're not gonna take it easy they're
gonna whine and try to negotiate try to
get more go back and forth and the same
is true with these others so that tells
us that it will take you two years of
hard work and saving and negotiating and
fighting and scrapping and arguing with
these people and getting it all in
writing all these different accounts
okay it's a lot of administrative work
for you but if you did that for two
years you can clear this debt for
somewhere around twenty twenty-five
thousand dollars total and you could
save up a little bit clear one save up a
little bit clear one save up a little
bit clear one and you know the last one
is the home equity loan and you save up
fifteen thousand and bone you knock it
out okay
that's your alternative to bankruptcy or
you can file bankruptcy either one but I
I think you can work through it but you
really have a lot of work ahead of you
to work through it but I think you can
do that you're broke you know any money
as you save up money you call and
negotiate with them now if you're gonna
go
that route make sure any settlement you
agree to that they agree to before you
give them any money two things you have
to remember get it in writing and never
an electronic access on your checking
account always in writing and don't let
them have access your checking account
and don't give them any information
about where your husband works or where
you bank or anything like that you have
to stay stay in the distance in the fog
and negotiate with them this is the Dave
Ramsey show Roderick is with us in
Pittsburgh hey Rodrick how are you I'm
doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up well yes in a nutshell
my wife and I are planning a move to
start our careers she is graduating you
know about a month or so well we both
have a substantial not a student loan
debt the neighborhood of well over
$600,000 $600,000 yes well over we're
both positions so freaking brain
surgeons
what's your specialization I'm family
medicine psychiatry oh my lord all right
these are not exactly high-paying fields
how'd you get six hundred grand in depth
of that well I'm personally I came from
a single-parent household and I had to
pay for college graduate school and
medical school so alone and my wife also
took out loans to pay for graduate
school and medical school so what do you
project your incomes to be first year
well for residency we're starting our
income will be about combined about a
hundred and eight thousand dollars a bit
but when you get out of residency what
do you predict your world comes to
bright when we gather our residency you
should at least triple if not quadruple
I think we would both make in the
neighborhood of about two hundred
thousand to start either a family man
behind or not well
income has increased significantly for
failing medicine in the federal here no
none okay I work with talks all the time
they'd only 100 house what you're
looking at
unless you get an unusual gig of some
kind if you can get 200 I'm not gonna be
mad at you you need it because you sure
have a dadgum huge mess on your hands
right what a mess
uh yeah yeah so you guys you guys need
to live like college students until this
is gone I don't care what your income is
you know and not good so the question
that I had was in tons of this debt is
it
I guess conceivable to consider it as
more of a mortgage in terms of debt when
you consider the baby steps there's no
mortgage but I wouldn't consider it a
mortgage no you need to clear it up two
years okay you know you're making four
hundred you need to live on 50 and clear
it up in two years right and that was
what does definitely the plan we don't
plan to buy a house or anything until we
clear up in the hallways the parties
how would you consider it a mortgage if
you're paying it off and well I was we
were thinking in terms of baby steps and
sort of the first years now I've been
paying off that and then building up
emergency fund
so we allocate we're making $400,000 a
year or $300,000 a year you're not gonna
need much of an emergency fund oh and
they said I'm just talking about
starting this year because I making that
much money isn't until about year one or
five you know so that's one of that's
what's scaring me here but yeah you need
to live on nothing and pay everything
above nothing towards this disaster you
need to be in panic mode dude I mean I
can't breathe and it's not even my dad
six hundred and seventy thousand dollars
worth of that and you're just nonchalant
about it
he won't you operating on me
unbelievable man what a mess yeah you
need to really really focus on living on
nothing no house buying no car buying no
vacations no eating out and completely
focus on cleaning up this mess to do
this is if you do not do that you're
gonna be in debt for decades if you're
not careful here I'm so sorry
what a horrible thing to be facing I
can't imagine how overwhelming that must
feel or should feel a Liz in Orlando al
how are you
I'm doing well sir how are you better
than I deserve what's up so I just
started your program and I'm on baby
step two and I have an issue I make
about 120,000 a year but I have about
125,000 that's and I have a vehicle that
is about nine hundred and ten dollar
payment a month my question is how do I
get out of this what can I do I don't
know I'm just small so this feels I'm
not sure what to do
holy crud nine hundred and ten dollars
what are you driving dude just a pickup
truck the Dodge pickup truck okay what
in the world is this thing I mean how
did you is a high interest rate high
interest rate sixteen percent seventy
three month payment I've been paying on
it now for about probably two years
twenty nine months audio on it today
what's the payoff today I believe it's
twenty nine thousand it's worth about
nineteen okay goodness gracious
mmm-hmm how much is your house payment
I'm thirteen hundred your truck payments
almost as high oh yeah I mean if I'm in
your shoes I'm waking up don't don't you
wake up and every time you get in this
thing and start the key on it you wish
it would explode I mean you got to be
kicking yourself like every time you
drive it right it was an absolutely yeah
I mean you make really good money
congratulations
yeah and really selling this truck is
not going to fix the whole 120 thousand
dollar problem but it helps with cash
flow so considerably and I gotta be
honest with you if I'm in your shoes
I've done a lot of stupid stuff out I
mean I've done stupid with steroids I
know what it looks like okay and so when
I do something stupid I don't like to be
reminded of it every day does that make
sense
Oh God if Dave was in there I'd be
selling it just so I didn't have to
remind me of it every day I mean I'm not
sure it's gonna make that big a
difference in your short-term finances
but I just wouldn't want the 16 percent
I feel like I'm being you know I'm being
abused every day which you are and I'm
looking at this thing it's like pointing
stupid arrows at my face every day I
would have to get rid of it for those
two reasons it helps also with the money
because the 910 dollars is gonna clear a
lot of debt for you month that's $1,000
a month towards your other stuff if we
can get you out of this so what I'm
gonna do is run out with the credit
union your credits obviously trashed and
see if you can talk them into borrowing
the difference where's the loan crisis
it's a Chrysler credit yep I didn't
realize they did subprime stuff like
that to that level Wow
okay yeah you gotta borrow that 10k that
you're in the hole or you gotta save it
up to get rid of it one of the two so
you can get the things sold where'd you
hear where'd you get the $19,000 value
what is that
I just Kelley Blue Book's is that retail
or wholesale that was if I sell to a
private price okay and that's probably
your real value then and you probably
rolled some negative into this too
didn't you
yeah it was about 2 grand yeah yeah that
makes sense
all right yeah I'm if I can find the
money to cover the difference that
you're in the hole if I'm in your shoes
I'm getting rid of it cuz I don't want
the reminder I don't want the 16% and I
need the 900 bucks to clear my dad it's
not like it clears all there's only 20%
of your dad so it's not doesn't really
fix your debt problem short-term but it
does do those three things and so I am
dumping it because it's just the whole
deal is just absurd Wow
I'm so sorry you're facing this ouch
ouch ouch ouch thanks for calling in
Scott is with us in Chicago hey Scott
how are you gonna call this sure what's
up so I'm on day number two and the
thing that seems to be doing the most
trouble and the most frustrating is I
have $60,000 in student loans so that's
to be paid back over the next
actually so I paid like the minimum
which I don't plan to do but so cost me
over $100,000
that's absurd it's not even an option
yeah
so what do you make oh well I make on a
thousand good so how fast are you know
50 what's that so how fast you're paying
off 50 one year I will I guess I guess
my question is why they don't drive off
why not
okay why not pay I'm not to that payment
yeah I'm so going off a couple of other
things
oh okay so you got other dad how much
other dad have you got in a car cool but
you make 100 grand are you single no
engaged oh good good cool when you're
getting married December 2nd oh okay you
haven't pay for part of that no good
good so so basically we've got from now
into December making $100,000 and you
got about $54,000 $55,000 where the dad
is that right okay so you're not quite
gonna make it in a year but you ought to
make it in 18 months shouldn't you well
a hundred - well let's just say 18
months 150 minus 60 is 90 you can't live
on 90 in the next nine 18 months not
counting taxes I guess I lost you there
someone okay let me try again
you make a hundred a year okay so a year
and a half of income would be a hundred
and fifty wouldn't it right - sixty
worth of debt would equal 90 - type -
some taxes right - or taxes but you
can't live on 90 over 18 months no
you're right I am NOT
no no you're you're broke man you're not
invested in retirement you're getting
out of death not even if it's not dude I
don't care if it's matched 20 times over
you got $50,000 in student loan debt you
just call me up whining about paying it
off over 20 years we got to change that
if you'll get this out of the way your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income and right now it's all
committed to somebody else I want their
name off your income in the next 18
months then you're in a position to boom
man you could smack the crap out of that
401k after that right that makes sense
to you yeah just leave it there but stop
adding to any retirement temporarily
wait you're a new you're a new listener
right yeah okay I'm sorry I was treating
you like an old listener I'm beating you
up I apologize okay so here's the thing
we teach a thing called the baby steps
or you do one thing at a time in order
in right with the premise the premises
of this that your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income if you have
no payments you're in a position to
build wealth very quickly and very
easily and that includes building first
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses so baby step one as $1000
start that's a little starter emergency
fund baby step two is no life
scorched-earth lifestyle or cleaning up
debt because we're gonna be we're gonna
be so intense and so focused and get it
out of our life as fast as possible
because you have sixty thousand dollars
of barrier between you and your dreams
and I want it gone boom ponch it okay
and when you knock that thing out then
that set you have to go back to that
thousand dollar raise it up to a fully
funded emergency fund by the time you do
that you're married six months okay okay
and you got her income in the mix which
is going to change the equation here but
I'm just using this as an example three
to six months of expenses are set aside
and now you've got a fully funded
emergency fund let's call that twenty
thousand bucks and you have no payments
in the world does that feel pretty good
yes now you step in and you don't take
the measly three percent match in the
401 K you
except puppy outter you take it up to
15% of your income then we'll save up
and pay off your house next and with no
house payment holder you everyone cool
by the time you're 40 you should be have
your house paid for and all this stuff
cleaned up and a paid for house and dude
you'll be a millionaire by the time
you're 45 if you do that guys yeah the
math works I'm not making this up I've
done it before so here's the thing well
you and your fiance are getting married
in October you said yeah okay so we have
a nine week class called Financial Peace
University you go once a week one night
a week for nine weeks
and it shows you all this stuff and it
shows you how to handle money it's not
get rich quick it's get rich slow it's
the hard way to do it but it works every
time and the number one cause of divorce
and money fights in America is are the
number one cause of marriage fights in
America is money and money problems so
I'm gonna give you to that class as my
wedding gift and I'm gonna show you
exactly how to do this stuff and then
you call me back if you've got any
questions I'm gonna pay for you to go
hold on Kelly's gonna pick up we'll get
you signed up and get you going
boom we'll get this whole thing started
out there guys it's amazing if you just
take a step back in that interesting how
you think twenty years I'm gonna be in
debt and then one conversation in some
basic math and you go hey hey wait a
minute I think I mean don't get rid of
this now the highest probability chance
you have to building wealth is to be
debt-free folks your highest probability
chance of getting out of debt is to be
very intense very deep cuts and do it
fast band-aid off quick snatch
that's the best way put
and so that's how you don't take it off
slow you snatch it you get after it
that's the highest probability of
getting out of debt which then gives you
the highest probability of building
wealth and being outrageously generous
throughout your life and being in
control because you have to learn to be
in control to pull this stuff off but
hey nobody wakes up a millionaire goes
how that happened it was accidental
no it's intentional steps people this is
the Dave Ramsey show tony is on the line
in tampa question for Ken Coleman today
hey Tony what's up hey Dave hey Ken are
you doing good are you sir doing good I
just lost my job this morning I'm 24
years old going on 25 and I just lost my
job and it was a six-figure income so
you know a hard job to find what in the
world happened and what were you doing
so I've been in the car business my
whole life kind of just got thrown into
it the whole family you know everybody's
in the car business for the same company
I was selling lots of cars first place
every single month
and you know some of the cars that were
selling they had you know bad CARFAX I'd
work with a guy for five days straight
and the CARFAX would be bad and I
decided to leave the car fact you know
out of the you know I didn't show the
guys the car fact so I guess that could
have been a lawsuit or something and
they ended up firing me it was
mercedes-benz so you know they're real
strict with everything you leave the
toilet seat open you might get clipped
hmm
well first of all we're sorry this is
not a fun day but I want at least
encourage your heart for a moment you're
gonna survive you've got to learn from
this anytime something like this happens
you don't want to move on from this you
want to take as much personal
responsibilities you need to and then
figure out okay
what do I learn from that not let that
happen again and move forward so six
figure income we've got to ask on the
Dave Ramsey show where you at
financially are you where are you at in
the baby steps do you have any kind of
emergency fund
yeah I've been putting a little money
away at no my job's real strict and the
security there's not too good I'm just
by you know knowing where the managers
are at mentally and that kind of
they're just real strict with everything
I've only worked there and I said
six-figure income but I've only worked
there this is my third month there and
my first second and this month I'm all
in first place with a perfect CSI which
is you know your surveys that come back
so my customers loved me but I was
thinking with emotion more than I was
with my head so I know that's where I
went wrong
well Tony so were you at do you have an
emergency fund at all what is it how
much um yeah I have about 15,000 dollars
saved up do you have any debt yes I do
how much my bills every month or right
around 2000 a month yeah but how much
debt do you need to pay off if you look
at all the money you owe how much how
much debt do I need to pay off I'm sorry
no debt to pay off I'm renting my
apartment and my car is least I know you
hate that Dave but it is least alright
Dave I'll let you handle the money stuff
in a second here's what you need to do
Tony you really need to I think you ask
yourself the question why did you do
what you did which got you in a
situation where there was a clear
company policy and you violated it and
they take that stuff serious and as a
result you're out of a job so you really
need to reflect on that we don't wanna
beat up on you but that's important
secondly do you love sales you're 24 do
you like to sell yeah I love to sell in
certain environments so there's certain
places I've sold that that I didn't
enjoy on the first real job that I did
like was Mercedes the clientele the
money of course and the cars I enjoyed
selling the cars all right you're 24
where'd you go to what did you go to
school for did you go to school and what
was it for what was your major
I started college and I was just gonna
get a business management degree because
I had no idea what I wanted to do so I
was like just to go to school for
something I ended up not going for I
ended up stopping school after about two
years you know once it started coming
out of my pocket I just really you know
didn't care about what they had to say I
was more interested in making money and
that kind of thing so for a couple years
now the professional poker player okay
well Tony you're all over the place so
I'm gonna give you a couple pieces of
advice and this is something you're
going to
need to do actively first things first
is you've got a little bit of a cushion
with that $15,000 you're single I'd get
rid of the lease obviously Dave kind of
can speak to that but I want you to sit
down with three people you can make it
five or seven I don't care but some
people who really know you they care
enough about you to tell you the honest
truth they'll be blatantly brutally
honest with you and I want you to ask
the question of yourself and then let
them answer it which is what is your
greatest talent what do you do better
than anything else
and then what do you care about if you
love selling but you want to sell
something that lines up with your values
I mean it matters to you then that's
where you need to be heading but before
you even make that big decision you need
to get employed and you need to lick
your wounds here and also learn some
valuable lessons Dave Tony my son is 25
and this is what I would tell him if I
heard this story from him number one you
have a tremendous upside you have a gift
with people and you have the ability to
sell what sometimes comes with that is a
BS artist and you've been biessing even
on the phone here toilet seat up is way
different than freaking not giving a
CARFAX report you should have been fired
you deserved it not because you're not a
good salesman because you completely
violated the thing here I'm a Mercedes
customer you completely violated that
you would have been fired if you were
working for me and I would have cried
because you're such a good salesman when
I quit when I fired you
and I would have cried for you because I
wouldn't want to break your little heart
but you man you just completely stepped
in it and you cannot allow your your
gift with people to think that that
entitles you to cut corners
that's the poker thing that's cutting
corners that's the going around the
carfax thing that's cutting corners your
gift with people doesn't give you the
right to cut corners it demands that you
go right through the middle and that
integrity become your number-one goal
posts that you check everything on from
this day forward if you'll take that
with your personal gift with people
you're going to make $200,000 a year for
the rest of your life you're going to be
very wealthy you're gonna have a lot of
healthy great customers because
I can tell you this about you you like
selling a quality product Mercedes a
quality product and you like dealing
with intelligent customers because most
of what most of Mercedes customers are
well heeled they love that product
because it's a quality product most of
them are very successful themselves
they're easy to sell to for that reason
again I'm one of them but you've got to
take that other little piece of this and
digest that part of it from today and
make that your goal post so I'm gonna be
the first one in your corner like Ken
said put three people in your corner
that loves you enough to tell you the
truth you have a tremendous gifting
young man you can be anything you want
to be you could be the CEO of a major
company with your ability to deal with
people in your ability to sell but you
can't you will never achieve that if you
shortcut if you think you are the if you
think you get to go around the side of
something because of your verbal
gymnastics Kim you can you and I both
have that ability and so it's talking to
both of us I've done the exact same crap
when I was his age here's the deal Dave
this is a road block or a stop sign that
he created for himself and it's a gift
at 24 to go wait a second this is a
temptation for anybody who loves to sell
you know this any others know how to use
a word properly and there's a phrase
there's a thrill in getting the deal
done yep and it it'll cause us to be
tempted to cut corners like you said
Dave and end up getting ourselves in big
trouble know why you love to sell and
love what you are selling so you're not
tempted to cut corners so if you get
this lesson from this firing you'll look
back when you're 34 and let's take a
tour and you'll say this is the best day
of my life if you take the lesson away
that they were right they were not petty
toilet seat up is petty you tried to
match it up with Betty it was not Betty
it was deserved but you're a good man
and you've got the ability to make big
money and do the right thing with this
gifting and you're gonna you're gonna be
somebody dude you call me back and I'll
help you I promise this is the Dave
Ramsey show Roland is with us in Joplin
Missouri hi Roland how are you all right
Dave thank you so much for talking and
thank you for sharing common sense sure
how can I help I've been I've heard you
speaking to people for us about loved
ones
the loved ones are making bad decisions
but I'm married to that person and some
of the bad decisions have kind of led us
and hurt our family led us into a bad
place weren't homeless and very much
behind on bills yourself I like to get
all the bills caught up we're about
$4,200 time on just regular bills of
rent electric utilities but you know how
is that her fault partly mine too
because I let it happen
yeah she long first off on the river a
truck driver and while I've been on the
road some of her friends that she had
had problems in their lives and become
homeless and she wanted to try and help
me so she let them move in the house at
the time didn't think it was a good idea
because we were kind of struggling
ourselves but she went ahead and did it
anyway and a lot of our resources have
went into the last eight months of
trying to help those people try and get
jobs and get back on their feet and when
where are they now I've gotten all of
these out of the house there's only I
thought you said you were homeless
well we became homeless two weeks ago
and before that how it happened we've
gone over your foreclosed on no behind
on the rent and addicted okay so where
are you living
currently the hotels campgrounds
whatever we can get into so obviously
all of those people you were helping are
now gone yes and so what is your income
right now okay and how far how much do
you owe in back rent
about a thousand dollars and how much D
and you said $4,200 and what else 1700
and electric
500 in gas think we got the water caught
up and the rest is mostly recent medical
bills and that's another three thousand
or two thousand or what about two
thousand yeah what kind of medical bills
what kind of medical event did you have
I have Crohn's disease sleep apnea and
it study trying to get the sleep apnea
taken care of and doctor's visits a lot
of times are you if I thought I'm 34
how long have y'all been married will be
ten years of September alright so if I
were to sit down and talk to her would
she tell me she's learned her lesson yes
and I've also tried to sit down to hold
on how kind of a dream meeting and see
what we can where we go from here mm-hmm
since you have learned your lesson and
what she tells me is that she doesn't
want a dream doesn't want to think about
it because she if we dream and it
doesn't come true she doesn't want to be
disappointed mm-hmm well let's dream not
about not being homeless how's that that
would be pretty cool to not be
disappointed you know and let's dream
about getting this little handful of
dirt you know five thousand dollars
changes your whole life what did she do
for a living she's disabled they say
some with kids this takes care of the
kids
and how much disability is coming in
well she's going through the disability
process right now it's kourt's what is
the nature of her disability physical
pain she had a head-on collision with a
bundt truck and has left her injuries on
the left side of her body that prevent
her from standing for long times and or
doing a lot of physical work but she
could do white-collar work I think so
yeah because you guys need some extra
income right now
well so I think she needs to find a job
so that you're not homeless
and so that $5,000 comes in and you
clean this mess up so let me tell you
what I'm hearing rolling okay I'm
hearing a couple who's every individual
part of their life and their marriage is
completely spiraling out of control
there are so many different variables
that are crazy and what you gave me in
about a three minute thing here that
it's no wonder y'all ended up where you
are and I'm not saying that to put you
down I'm saying that there's a lot more
going on here than your wife couldn't
control her spending there's a marriage
breakdown there's her absolute lack of
judgment that's beyond belief and yet
she's supposed to be watching over
children and she's disabled and yet not
getting disability so she needs to be
working and you've got to somehow
interface with all of this and take over
these bills and put the family back on I
don't know that a dream meeting is in
order a crisis intervention might be in
order but I don't think a dream meeting
is in order we might have a nightmare
meeting like how do we get out of this
nightmare but that that start so what I
would tell you to do if you were my 34
year old little brother and you are is
to grab a local pastor and sit down with
them and let's start the process there
with marriage and spiritual walk and you
guys start trying to just push some of
the crazy out of your life and let's try
to get back to some solid ground in the
middle in the center of your life and
then rebuild your relationships based on
that and start making positive
responsible decisions both of you that
involve work ethic involve for galatea
involved laying out a plan and you can
do every bit of that it's very very
possible but I I think that's where I
would start if I were you is I'd pick up
phone call local pastor say hey we're
homeless it's our fault we're not coming
in for money we're coming in for some
leadership and I as a young dad a young
husband I need some guidance pastor and
let that pastor counsel you as a man and
counsel you guys in your marriage and
let's lead you back into putting
putting together a solid plan and I'll
put you in Financial Peace University in
the area there but if that's all you do
it's not going to work because there's a
lot more going on here than just a
financial issue or to your financial
problems are the symptom of all the
crazy going on in your life and man you
got to sweep the crazy out of the
corners over there that's what's that's
what's overdue so if you do that you'll
see this turn around but hold on Kelly
I'll pick up we'll get you signed up for
Financial Peace University and we'll try
to figure out what we can do from there
so hey thank you for the call are you
Jessica hi Dave how are you better than
I deserve what's up all right so you
want in off three years but and I've
read the Total Money Makeover book my
husband is not a fan I have to put that
out there first but we have some serious
debt and it's all pretty much you don't
loan debt from my husband going to law
school and so right now we are in an
income based repayment plan which so we
haven't really been worried about this
debt because after all if they're like
20 or 25 years it'll be forgiven
quote-unquote but I happen to look at
one of the balance statements a cop like
a few weeks ago and it's gone from 100 a
hundred and ninety thousand in ciemins
at two hundred fifty thousand and
student loan debt and so because of the
interest and so I'm kind of I'm starting
to panic because I just mmm sorry I
don't know how to get out of it what's
your household very okay
what's your household income my husband
he makes 90th out about ninety thousand
a year and when your service you know we
I was gonna say you know we bought into
this sort of idea that a lawyers going
to make a lot of money so it wasn't a
big deal to take the school loans out
but he's basically he started working
public
right out of law school and then you
know his salaries increased over the
last four years about 60 grand but it's
still obviously not gonna put a dent in
the school loan issue so how old is he
35 35 so when you say he's not a fan you
mean he's not a fan of getting out of
debt it's not that he's yeah I'm not
sure I don't know exactly why he he
doesn't care for your program it's not
the getting out of debt part I think he
doesn't want to think about the school
loan and I don't think he wants to I
think part of our problem is that we
don't know what to do about it
and so we see beans and rice like I've
cut our budget because I do listen and
so I've cut our budget down and we don't
have cable we don't have a lot of the
extras or cell phone bill is like less
than $80 a month for both of us because
his work pays part of his and I mean so
I tried to cut down in all of the areas
that I can and you know and food and all
those things which are not saving money
and you're not paying extra on the debt
so you're not doing a written exactly
you're not doing a written plan or every
dollar you're just cutting stuff I'm
cutting stuff this is the first month
because of I looked at it a few months
ago notes or a few weeks ago and start
listening to you again this is the first
month where I've really done the budget
out so that we're going to have and we
have about eleven hundred dollars extra
a month after all of our bills are paid
that's do you have so the school loans
and then we we've had we've had a camper
for a few years so that we like 13 just
under 14,000 on that and then we had
bought a truck last year to pull the
camper and then we owe 38 thousand on
that but we don't have any credit card
debt or anything like that but so you
just guys you know I know you're scared
but you just
keep doing stupid stuff well yeah
because you did you know so I'm hopeless
about getting out of debt and so I'm not
gonna willing to listen to anybody I'm
putting words in his mouth so let's go
about $38,000 truck to pull our camper
Wow Wow well part of the thing was I
wanted to sell our house last year I
actually wanted to live in a camper we
homeschool and I wanted to be able to
you know rode school and kind of do some
nut stuff so the idea that we was that
we were gonna sell the house and then we
were gonna we were gonna live in the
camper and then that all changed because
he wasn't ready to do that but we had we
bought the truck in anticipation of that
so yeah we're not the I feel like we're
smart people but financially not doing
super smart things and then we bought a
new house disposed because we sold our
house but there's a lot there's a lot
you guys can't get on the same page and
so depending on whether he wants to slap
his foot down or not you guys are
lurching back and forth from stupid
thing to stupid thing because you don't
have you not having do not have a clear
goal and you are not relationally on the
same page on any of these decisions and
it's causing it's causing them to
multiply the problem instead of doing
oil you need to identify a clear concise
goal that the two of you are willing to
sacrifice to get to and that means sell
the truck and sell the camper and it's
the house getting equity in it it
probably has a little bit of equity in
it but it's from you know we just bought
it in August so yeah I mean yeah and
then we're gonna get on a tight budget
and we're not going out to eat we're not
going on vacation when we begin to
attack this and as his income goes up
it's probably a five-year plan to pay
off $150,000 for the student loan debt
but until you get rid of this it's not
going to do anything but get worse
because the income-based always goes
with negative amortization which means
that the interest is higher than the
payments you're paying so you're going
backwards and exactly just it's it's
financial suicide and yeah and the fact
that you cannot seem to get on the same
page and i don't know i'm i don't know
whether i'm hearing fear from him or
arrogance from him or maybe both but the
way you're describing the
decision-making in the way you all
interact it's not healthy and so you
guys got some work to do on that to get
on the same page I really can't help you
unless both of you want to do something
because what you you can't cut cable and
fix this right you can't not go to
Starbucks and fix this this is going to
require a Hercule it's a huge mess and
it's are gonna require a unified
approach between the two of you to be
able to win financially because you know
when one of you goes and makes a
decision then the other one grabs the
wheel and coarse corrects you're jumping
back and forth from stupid is stupid and
really magnifying this mess I'm sorry
for you I know you're scared but I'm I
mean the fact that you guys can't sit
and have a good conversation and come to
a good conclusion to the point that
you're you know on a national radio show
crying tells me something about y'all's
relationship and that that's scaring ya
that's scaring me so the two of you need
to work on that I I'm gonna send you to
marriage counseling first is what I'm
gonna do and when you get back from that
if you want to go through Financial
Peace University Kelly you Kelly's gonna
pick up she'll get your contact
information and you can contact her at
that point and then I will be happy to
pay for you to go through Financial
Peace University but I don't want you
going to Financial Peace University by
yourself because you're gonna end up
divorcing this guy if you do and that's
and I don't want to cause that that's
not that's not where I want to go
because you're gonna start having real
firm knowledge based opinions and and
he's not gonna play that for that this
has got he's got to be in on the idea
and you guys got you have to have a
unified front on where you're going with
this it's the only way it's gonna work
for you so you need to sit down with
your pastor and start working on some of
these relationship issues to where he's
as a good husband he should be a whole
lot more concerned about how scared you
are than he is and willing to do
something about it if there was
something I could do for Sharon and she
was this scared a hundred percent of
time I'm gonna do it
and and you know you truthfully you've
got a right to be afraid because this is
a pretty sizable mess and doing nothing
about it is not gonna bring you to a
good place so I'm so sorry you're facing
this but hold on and Kelly will pick up
she'll take your information then if you
guys come back from marriage counseling
and you want to go to FPU we will pay
for it I do not want you going by
yourself though that would be an
unhealthy thing for you guys right now
brian is with us in Sioux Falls South
Dakota hey Brian how are you I'm doing
great Dave how's your day better than I
deserve what's up so I have a question
that's listened for 12 years your
guidance has actually enabled me to ask
I am 26 years old recently invented a
new electrical wall place for hiding
Graduate sensor wires and I'm about to
retire congratulations big dog well done
man
that's awesome so so you invented this
thing and you've sold it for a bazillion
dollars so I actually sold it with a
forty thousand mile road trip listening
to your show all the way across the
country for a year just going
door-to-door and it's now nationwide
distributors and it is taking off and
running itself okay
and so well nothing runs itself so you
built a company or you've sold the item
to a company or how's it being run so I
am still dying at part-time basically
coordinating voices between my
distributors and my suppliers but my
workload has drastically dropped below
the 40 hour week mark Wow good for you
okay and so III have no buy of no okay
so what's your question we've done very
very well obviously oh it's all day
because of you and everything's been
cash flowed you know we're just as a
design engineer and gettable Tilford 20
you know two thousand dollars for a
lawyer for months I'd be able to cash
flow and just did that till I got ready
to launch so what that financial
guidance allow me to do is I'm still
single how do I approach any eligible
girl I meet and what do I tell her about
my income
well it's interesting because you don't
want to be a target is what you're
saying for the wrong exactly
you don't need a gold-digger we used to
call them in the old days Wow well my
son is 25 and he kind of has the same
problem because he's my son right he
didn't have any more money because I'm
not dead but someday he's gonna be in
really good shape you know so you know
and he and I have talked about this a
time or two but it's not ever really
been a problem
I think the healthier you are personally
as an emotionally and spiritually the
more normal you are in terms of I don't
mean normal in a bad way but I mean
you're just a regular person but if
you're whole you're not needy
emotionally
you've not got some kind of weird ego
thing going on which I don't hear and
talking to you you just sound like a guy
who came up with a great I didn't worked
his butt off to me that's what it sounds
like and so just be that guy and you
know do you have any family in your life
yep that one brother and my parents
still around okay cool I would use them
as a filter with young ladies that
you're that you're seeing and just to
have other people look over your
shoulder in case you've got a blind spot
for one and they see things and give
them permission to speak to you about it
and go you know if you think somebody's
after me for the wrong reasons speak up
okay and go ahead and just say that out
loud
Daniel has two sisters and I can promise
you they're filters you can't pass the
sister mafia your big time you know so
that happens you know and but I think
the more hole you are spiritually the
more hole you are emotionally mental
health wise the more you're going to
just naturally repel those kinds of
people I meet for instance guys who go
through a midlife crisis
and you know you know marry the supposed
trophy wife right the second wife that's
after money kind of thing and most the
time it's those guys just aren't very
sure themselves as men and so they
attract that you know they need they
need harm candy to feel good about
themselves and you're not just don't be
that guy you know you're looking for
someone you're looking for somebody's
beautiful on the inside yeah and by the
way it's a plus if they are on the
outside but I mean it's they're
beautiful on the inside and and you're
just gonna take your time and then of
course where you're meeting people
matters because you know where do
quality people hang out and that's where
you need to be hanging out but as far as
when to disclose the net worth I think
you do that or your income or those
kinds of things the fact that you've
become wealthy later rather than sooner
but certainly you don't want to spring
it on someone but you know after you're
engaged that would be weird
you wouldn't want to do it but but you
know you don't go out the first date and
start spouting off about it you're gonna
track the wrong kind of people
and I would be pretty secretive about it
not we're not in a weird way but I just
wouldn't live a real flashy lifestyle
that that you know Daniel drives a
pickup with about a hundred thousand
miles on it he doesn't he didn't have to
but he driving in one stride probably
but he does were very well on his own
that's my son as an example so you know
you can just do whatever and that way
you're not putting off signals that that
that that there's wealth here but then
yeah the more serious you get the more
you begin to unpack it and I would just
begin with some other money
conversations and make sure those go
well and that the relationship continues
before I got into that so yeah it's
certainly not a first date thing and
it's certainly long before engagement
but somewhere along though you long
there you just start talking about work
ethic and saving and how they feel about
wealth and how they feel about that kind
of stuff and so now let me ask you this
is is this over ten million dollars so
has a market potential about 43 million
a year that we're currently extracting
only about 1% of oh you're making about
a lot it or a choice in the world so
you're making four or five hundred
thousand a year already yes net yes okay
and that's what that has just started
yep so we are
I'm very much in the baby stages where
I'm used to my 80k a year engineering
sorry yes and I told my friends around
me if you've seen me change yell at me
and be very honest because I don't want
to change from the young conservative
Midwestern Christian that I started with
I don't want to become a different
person just because I now can be yeah
well you need to be a different person
but you don't necessarily need to show
at all yeah you need to be you need to
be capable of managing more and that's
gonna be different you know it's a
different thing making 400 then it isn't
making 80 so I well here's the thing I
do not recommend prenups in normal
situations but this is not a normal
situation and so because you're probably
going to have a multi-million dollar net
worth before you're married is what it
sends to me like and so you probably do
want a prenup in those cases are you at
least need to consider it and it's not
because she's weird or you're weird it's
because when there's that much money
around weird can just show up in the
form of her mother or her aunt or
something like that you know and then
the influences start moving and it it it
negates their influence when there's a
free done agreement now again I don't
believe in prenups in normal situations
but where there's extreme situations I
do recommend them Candice is with us in
st. Louis hi Candace how are you hi baby
Ramsey how are you better than I deserve
what's up I am in $200,000 and that I
haven't even finished college and right
now I can't work in the minimum job I
mean minimum wage job and
and I'm just trying to get a hold of my
life right now
so I'm just trying to get some guidance
at this point what were you doing going
$200,000 in debt
well I was on school for filming videos
and at first I was for interior designed
and I transferred to a different school
for filming video so that's pretty much
the school's work that our book that I
was going to were out of state good lord
yeah and I'm not they're not bother you
that you were running up that much dad I
mean how to cheat that's how do you
Ramona I went to school right out of
high school and my parents they didn't
know much about you know financing or at
least they didn't teach me anything
about it they just told me that I'll
have these student loans and I had to
pay them back
and I really wasn't conscious of you
know even long in that sense so how much
do you like before you graduate I have
only like a year left and I want to go
back to school to get my degree
Yeah right now I just want to at least
try to take the big chunk out of the
student loans at least a little bit of
it yeah well you don't you know you're
not I'll do that make a minimum wage
obviously you're bad you're barely
eating making it how old are you I'm 28
this is another thing that I am working
on so I am working on a movie and I'm
putting my money that work into the
movie into the movie and I also have
sponsorships that's helping to fund the
movie and I also have a partnership as
well and so I'm just taking a leap of
faith that this movie will bring a
substantial amount of money what makes
you think that
um it's your faith in I believe the
storyline it's a good storyline and it's
a good content to cover I mean do you
know anything about distributing a movie
and monetizing it well this is the thing
I mean it's an independent movie and I
know that my partner he is going to help
you know that any of the funds that we
need in order to get it to where we need
to go basically you know he's it's
basically his faith into my project
that's that's how okay I want to see you
live your dream and I want to see the
movie be produced and and get out there
but I'm also duty-bound as your old ugly
uncle to tell you the truth and that is
is that you have a pattern since you're
20 years old of entering into things and
not carrying what they cost and not
knowing what you're getting into
I mean the movie business is a
rough-and-tumble business independence
that independent movies they go out
there and make big money are almost none
right you're got to be aware of that
yeah I'm aware I'm totally aware of you
can't you know you can't listen I'm a
person of faith but there's there's
faith and then there's just dreaming and
so I want you to have a solid business
plan by which your faith is executed and
my partner is going to put some money
into it and get it where it needs to go
that's not a business plan the movies
yeah movies get made every day that
nobody sees that's true and lots of
independent movies get made every day
that nobody sees and I'm okay with you
working on your dream but you you've got
to start entering into things whether
it's your continuation of your education
whether it's the time you're spending on
this movie the money you're spending on
this movie or whatever it is you've got
to start entering into things with your
eyes more open
and just going oh we're just going to
start this and it'll all work out
because maybe it hasn't been working out
and if you smell let's say you let's say
you spend two years on this movie and
you get zip out of it
oh no I'm not spending two years won't
go ahead but I mean that that's you know
you've got to have a an understanding of
the behind the scenes part of how a
movie gets launched and how it turns
into money that you don't have today
otherwise you can't spend your time on
it and because it's not a dream anymore
it's it becomes a nightmare like you're
going to school as your parents dream
for you to go school but nobody thought
about what you were spending on that
schooling and so you've gotten yourself
in an absurd scenario with $200,000 in
student loan debt or can a minimum-wage
job it's just a horrible place to be for
you darling I just feel so bad for you
so I want you to start things in your
life that you can see in detail how they
can occur and that is faith - that's
wisdom is what it is and wisdom goes
with faith and so step by step by step
how am I going to get my career rolling
actually make some money a high
probability of making some money not one
shot in the dark which is really what a
movie is it's one shot in the dark and I
don't mind you working on that but that
probably ought to be your side gig while
you work on something else that makes
you some money and you get over there
finish your degree and then you get out
there making 50 60 80 100 1250 thousand
you know you get yourself a career track
going kiddo so you can get this mess
cleaned up and you can live a life
because right now you've got this this
monstrous oppression over the top of
your head of this debt I'm so sad for
you I wish I could just wave a wand and
make it go away but what I want to hear
you what I want you to hear and I want
you to hear me loving you and not saying
I'm not a dream killer I'm not a dream
stealer
but I am somebody that tries to prevent
nightmares from occurring and right now
you got a nightmarish occurrence with a
student loan debt and if you don't
develop a detailed plan on how this
movie turns into money and you keep
working on it you're entering into
another nightmare so you need to have a
pattern where you what Stephen Covey
said in the books this
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
is you you begin with the end in mind
and it's not just I'm gonna make this
movie and I have faith that's going to
make me a bazillion dollars that that
those are words that that indicate you
don't know what you're doing and you
need to go find what you're doing and
that's the that's when you put wisdom
and faith together and as you start
doing those things you're gonna see some
differences I'm not trying to hurt your
feelings and it's not my goal here I'm
trying to love you well kiddo while
you're here on the air with me so I want
you to go through our class Financial
Peace University since I picked on you
and I picked on you for your own good
but I want you to go through the nine
week class I will pay for it I'm gonna
give it to you for free because you need
some good people in your life to gather
around you and help you walk through
this that can see the end in mind with
you as far as the this being this debt
and getting your money under control and
really getting your career on track too
so I'll tell you also Kelly when we pick
up and you give her a Financial Peace
University also give her the book start
and Candice I want you to read that book
as soon as it comes in the mail once you
sit down that day and read that book it
won't take you that long it's a quick
read and it'll really help you get your
arms around what I'm talking about where
you lay out a plan a roadmap to go
towards being awesome and I want you to
be awesome I want you to win but um you
know you have to hand that book you know
start takes you through that roadmap
it's what it does and it'll help you do
that so hang on Kelly I'll pick up and
we'll get you in Financial Peace
University and get you that book and if
I can help you all your fighting through
all this you call me I'll walk with you
I'm on your team I'm not here to kill
your dreams I'm here to keep from
turning that keep them from turning into
nightmares hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]